we are thrilled in fact to have Marlene
with us Marlene booth with us she is an
MFA has actually produced a number of
films that really are wonderful
commentaries in a variety of different
issues that we all are somewhat familiar
with but certainly could learn a lot
more about and the film that she is
introducing us to today is about three
generations of working mothers and of
course in the school we spend a lot of
time talking about the kind of burdens
that working women oftentimes carry
those of us who are working women not
really but I think the contribution that
she makes through this film is one that
is multiple because indeed she is
looking at working mothers who represent
a variety of different groups for those
of you who have seen the announcement of
this particular event you know that she
has received a number of grants in
support of her work I don't want to
spend a lot of time going through her
accomplishments but we are tremendously
proud to have her here today and I do
want to introduce her now and then give
her an opportunity to share her work and
also her ideas with us Thank you Thank
You Jeanette and very much and thank you
those of you who came out today to see
the film this is a film I'm just gonna
speak briefly by way of introduction and
then someone will answer the phone it's
a film that was that I made actually in
the early 90s as a young working mother
and and one of one of the objects of my
being a working mother is right there in
the back and my daughter
Amira who is a student at the at
Teachers College and has her own
appearance in the film I made the film
in the early 90s when I thought the
issue of
there's working and the controversy
surrounding mothers working would be an
issue for only a few years it never
occurred to me in my wildest imagination
that we would still be talking about
this issue in a heated way so many years
later so I'm startled by that and I'd
love to have you think about that as you
look at the film I'm thinking about it
all the time and would love to discuss
that and issues that the film raises
with you so let's begin the film I'm
reminded of a lot of things looking at
that at that film again but I want to
introduce my best girl from the film and
Oh leave Craig who did all kinds of
things on that film including me were
there on the first shoot which was the
last thing that's right that's right so
I've known Anne for about 28 years now
and that was a merest voice at the end
and I guess you've decided what you want
to be when you grow up yes right right
but there's still time right so so one
of the things that I that I remembered
looking at that was that the film
started out actually as a film looking
at the effect on day care of budget cuts
during the Reagan administration but it
was it was nobody was really doing
studies that early about what was
happening to day care because of budget
cuts so it ended up it morphed into a
film about working mothers looking at at
these three these three generations but
one of the things that struck me as I
began to do research was that there was
so much ink about working mothers and
guilt working mothers felt and the
effect of work on mothers and and no one
had talked to children no one had gone
to the grown children of working mothers
and said what was the experience like
for you so part of my motivation in
looking for three generations was to in
fact hear those voices which I hadn't
heard
and hadn't seen in the literature and
then I wondered what it was like to grow
up in a family there where that was a
family tradition and so I began looking
for the three generations and that was
one of the things that took the longest
it was very tough to either find
families in which there were three
living generations of mothers who had
worked or if I found three generations
it was hard having all three generations
wanting to speak so I had found one
family I spent a lot of time with them
the grandmother had needed to go to work
because her husband was an alcoholic and
ultimately though her daughter was eager
to speak and her granddaughter was eager
to speak she felt in credit had been
years earlier and I think the husband
was no longer living
she felt enormous shame about going
public about having been the wife of an
alcoholic so that was the end of that
family they didn't want to to be in it
there was another family I courted in
California again three generations and I
think I'm trying to remember which
generation it was I think it was the
grandmothers generation the grandmother
had had to put one or two of her
children in an orphanage at one point
there was just no other I mean this the
issue of child care weighed so heavily
on people how do you mean that's what
they mother Robinson almost lost a child
in that trough and that sort of incident
happened repeatedly and so people really
have limited options what what would you
do for child care people still have
limited options and and she was ashamed
of of talking about that so that was the
end of that family so it was it was
difficult finding three families where
the grandmother what didn't have
Alzheimer's and could talk and the
granddaughter worked but ultimately
these I found these three families
something else that happened in the
course of working in this film and off
in the case of all three families the
women had not had
conversations they had not asked each
other about work and raising children
because it was what the family it was
it's the way we all are with family
history what goes on is something that
seems not worth asking about and so for
many of them this was the first time
that the questions that got raised
during the course of the filming were
raised and that ended up sparking
conversations some of which take place
in the film and many of which took place
after the filming was finished so that
was that was sort of an interesting
piece of this oh oh and I guess you know
I guess in the end of the last the last
family that that's profiled the Robinson
family
Katie of course is a family day care
provider and and though I hadn't
specifically looked to ask someone who
took care of other people's children
what that experience was like the two
experiences of raising her own children
but also taking care of other people's
children that gave me that advantage to
have the sort of dual voice in in one
person but also being very interesting
so I'm very eager and and you know and
one of the thing I just said one more
thing and then I'm really eager to hear
what you have to say as I read about
Marissa Mayer and the other CEOs who are
now sounding off about women and work
and have their own solutions for what is
right for America's families based upon
having enormous incomes and and
conflating I think the issue of of
raising the glass ceiling but at the
same time how to do childcare and not
really looking at the realities of the
lives of all American women I'm struck
again by how often the conversation is
raised only when we look at upper middle
class women that that the mistake I made
in looking initially at women who could
be who could serve as models as working
mothers was that I was looking in the
wrong
laughs I ignored my own auntie's who who
in fact had worked in my uncle stores
and who had had been clerks and done
things like that because we tend to
think of of work only in the way that it
might be profiled in the Atlantic or
People magazine or something like that
so so there's always a huge part of the
conversation that that doesn't involve
the people it should involve and I think
that's that's something to consider too
as we think about this issue that just
hasn't gone away I'm again I'm still I'm
amazed by that I'm amazed that it that
it it's still a burning issue that there
are still tensions between women who
stay home and women who work and that
the workplace hasn't yet come up with
across the board or government
comfortable solutions that work in the
interests of families so I'm interested
to hear what all of you have to say and
Craig yes yes right right
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah yeah right
yeah yeah yeah yeah they're all right
thank you yeah and and that's both good
and bad I think
I was actually suggested
mm-hmm
right right right right yeah yeah
right
right right right right right right
yeah no I think I yes and uniquely women
carry that that burden right right in
the jet and the general societal
discussion makes it worse
we'll talk yeah
mmm
in the third generation or in the middle
generation you're either one can you
hear me now no were you finding that
that the daughters of working mothers
were deciding that they didn't want to
work because they didn't want to put
their children through what they had
been through did that come up in your
research among the women I filmed or
among the women who didn't want to be
filmed among the women who you were like
when you're trying to cast for them for
the film that that didn't end up being
an issue so much no because if they were
women who didn't want to work then they
didn't fit the profile I was looking for
yeah so this seems like it's ripe for an
update have you considered going back
for the next generation which would be
the fourth generation and if so their
filmmakers yes and if so do you and you
know what you were just saying right
after the film made me think that you
feel like not much has changed do you
really think that that would be the case
that this would not the fourth
generation wouldn't really add much
that's different than what you've
already gotten this film well I hadn't I
hadn't thought of that
so it's a good idea my guess my guess is
that those fourth generation young women
are working that would be my guess and
perhaps working without the kind of
ambivalence that troubled their mothers
or at least trouble some of their
mothers but I don't know I haven't I
haven't gone back to see and
I know I haven't been in Boston for ten
years so I haven't I haven't been in
touch with him but I probably wouldn't
through the miracle of Google it would
probably not be so hard to to find them
I don't know but you know judging from
what I read in in the popular press it
seems like it is still at least we're
led to believe that it's still an issue
I don't know there are women here who
were in their 20s and 30s right yes I do
think that it it's still very much is an
issue and is getting a lot more
publicity as you're speaking to the new
lean in concept that's come out and what
one class of women are putting out there
and I appreciated you making that
comment that it very much is class
oriented that it's coming from upper
middle class upper class women and
there's a huge population of women that
are not having their voices heard and
we're not really hearing what are their
reasons or going to work is it out of
necessity or is it also out of choice
right but I think very much for myself
as a young 30 year old it still runs
through my mind and I grew up in a I'm a
third oh I'm not a mother yet but my
mother worked and her mother worked and
I am now in Social Work school thinking
I'm planning to work as well when I have
children but still in that feminine
mindset I still kind of have some of
those thoughts about am I going to lead
that life and feel guilty right about
the choices that I'm making right and I
you know I I worry a lot about
policymakers only hearing the louder
voices that that are out there the
people who get depressed are not women
who don't have choices so that when when
people talk about I mean the need for
good affordable day care across the
board which seems to me at at a base
level would have been
that had been solved should have been
something that had been that was talked
about and considered seriously a long
time ago but I think if what people are
are imagining if they don't know anybody
who's a working mother and when they
think about working mothers they're
thinking about the women who are getting
on daytime TV and writing books they're
getting the wrong picture because
somebody who doesn't have a choice is
not likely to be on Oprah I guess oh
praise not anymore but you know I mean
it's not likely to be on a show or to be
interviewed someone wouldn't find such a
woman and so those voices aren't heard
and the needs of real women aren't
articulated and that's that's I think a
big problem yeah Artie I knew
grandfather's and then my mother worked
implicit in the film is the underlying
economics of it and what struck me is
that the grandmother generation all
started out in what would today be
considered poverty and yet it appears as
if each of these families made it into
at least some level of the middle class
and I wondered if you did take it into a
fourth-generation where people are now
falling out of the middle class yeah and
you know if that would even be possible
anymore right right I think that I think
that's a really good question yeah
that's also I think you know another
thing and you referred to it I think in
the you know the introductory part of
the film where you know back in you know
into the 50s at least it was possible
for one breadwinner to support a large
family and so at a certain point you
know in the feminist movement I think
there was that decision to work because
we want to work yeah but now I think
people have been forced back into
working because they have to work it's
you need at least two incomes for a
family if not yeah that's right yeah I
don't know I mean it's as I as I watch
there's so many American things that run
through this to it so
I missed about America to own one's own
home and I think ultimately all three of
the granddaughters did own their own
homes and I think that's a real question
to raise with the next generation in
fact the homeowners would that be a
dream probably yes and and do they and I
don't I don't know the answer today
worth finding out yes yes I wanted to
know when double but the double burden
was a thought or a dream in your mind I
mean and you I don't know if you went
about talking to people about hey this
is something I want to do curious to
know what that was like for you and what
kind of support you got or pushback
right right right
it was hard to know where to begin to
find three generations I actually began
looking in first I began to ask that ask
everyone I knew did they know anyone and
the Robinson family the last one to
appear is the first family I met and I
met them because someone I called and I
don't even remember wasn't a close
friend it was a friend of a friend or a
friend of a friend of a friend used kt4
family day care so that was my
introduction to that family it was Katie
you know usually one generation was the
generation that said I want to do this
this is important to do and I want our
family's history recorded that was where
there was a sense of pride in there you
know and what they had done well I mean
I think probably part of why I changed
its focus from effects on day care in an
era of initiative what looked at that
point in the early 80s like huge budget
cuts they've since been trumped by even
more enormous budget cuts that one could
never have imagined people thought there
were other more burning more burning
issues and and what happens with the
film is you look for a right grant
proposals and if you're lucky enough to
get a grant that gives you enough
credibility to then really
in the research so I can't remember at
which point I got a grant I had a I had
a fellowship at the hunting what was in
the bunting Institute and that helped
and they've had a grant before then I
can't quite remember it took a while I
mean I think people felt like why why
look at that at that issue and it was
certainly very tough I mean again 20
there's been the rise of the memoir and
a first-person reportage as a way of
storytelling that was what's still
somewhat new in the early 90s so the
idea of in fact telling your own story
in your own words having a history that
that to some people look like this is
just what we did to get by why who says
this is worthy of a story it was
sometimes hard to convince people I
think more than more than the need to
convince funders it was actually sort of
the obverse of what has happened in my
history is a filmmaker since it was
convincing the people whose stories I
wanted to tell that their stories were
worth telling and that they were the
people who could best tell that story so
that was that was part of the you you
know you are important in your voice
matters that was that was very new a lot
of people I think it's that you know I
mean again think about the voices we
don't hear and and why and what those we
don't even know what those voices sound
like because they're not they're not
give an airtime so I think yeah so I
think that was that was really the
biggest challenge yes
question I'm curious about does double
burden reference anything in particular
I'm curious how you came up with this
title for the film I mean I always have
a hell of a time with titles yeah and
I'm trying to think about how that title
came about I think I must have seen it
referencing in fact worked family things
then there was a large piece of
potentially of the film that didn't make
it in which was historical research
going through women's magazines dating
back to the 20s and I think at some
point there was talk about a double
burden and I thought that's that's a
title that'll work well and I'm curious
about it because the term burden has a
negative connotation I know I think
about you know a message that's being
sent with the film and one sort of
impact that might have I think you're I
think you're right I think you're right
I think at one point it might have been
double burdens double Joy's I mean you
know there's a lot of time spent sort of
losing sleep over titles trying lots of
things out and ultimately you need to
give the film a title and move forward
so that's that's what it became I can't
now remember what else I was considering
but that seemed to seem to work there
was an earlier film the film I had done
isn't my thesis film for my MFA was
about three single women in the early
years of the women's movement when the
notion of going public as a single woman
with pride was new and that film was
called by themselves which a friend of
mine thought of and I thought that was a
clever title so I thought I'd try to
work in the mode of what were clever
titles but I I think you're right I
think it's i think it's double edged
double burden double edged tomorrow did
you hear
yeah-yeah-yeah-yeah-yeah was her book
called up a burden it was called the
double shift yeah but that's why I
thought of immediately when I saw the
title yeah
and that was in it when did that come in
I can't remember oh I'm not sure I'm er
I read it probably at least 15 years ago
so it's been around for a while but
she's written extensively about families
and the economic dynamic of families and
how women are still expected to do all
the housework and the childcare and
everything even if they are making more
money than the husbands and the marriage
so she talks a lot about some of the
issues that you write I think someone in
a woman's history talked about how
people would would have sociate
sociologists would talk about the double
burden of child-rearing and work and
when I read that it was in a pro
sentence I thought that could that could
work as a title maybe that's probably
yes I suppose I really enjoyed the
archival footage we pulled together for
the film that was really amazing that
you could find that the woman made milk
carrier and the women picking the cotton
witching yeah thank you thank you well
the one that was most amazing to me
because you know what you do is you is
you go to the National Archives so that
the Library of Congress and you ask a
researcher to send you two hours worth
of footage about work or something or
Mississippi in you watch it and then in
two hours you know an hour and 58
minutes is nothing that you can use and
then what happened with the the bacon
footage she had described that and I
there was nothing I think I asked for
like meat-packing footage or something
so it's you know an hour and 58 minutes
of just the most dreadful meat-packing
footage you can imagine I fell asleep it
was warm in my house in the winter I'm
watching and nodding off and suddenly I
woke up and there is somebody packing
bacon on I thought I just gotta loosen
ated that wasn't really there in Irene
why on this was in the era of VCRs and
there it was it was exactly what she
described so that was that to me was the
most there are a few other things that I
couldn't help thinking about as I watch
the movie and one of them is you know
this is really as you mentioned earlier
uniquely American yeah
because as the world becomes so much
more global and we think about working
women within the context of the world
when you go to different countries work
is just life you know so it is something
that's named in America I think I just
came back from Africa maybe a few months
back and what women do there is not work
it's just life you know it's hard to
describe this but that's also what you
see in many other parts of the world so
that's one thing and then the other
thing is clearly you define this as a
movie that's about women
within an urban setting who came from
and oftentimes non urban settings you
know so I couldn't help but thinking
about all the different dimensions of
women over time in different contexts
and how their lives were shaped and how
their opportunities even you know came
forward so it's fascinating
right right right so what did they do
for child care in these other countries
um it's in some instances you know for
example when I went to Uganda because in
fact the population is somewhat
decimated by hiv/aids you see not women
taking care of children but you see
children taking care of children so in
some instances I saw kids who were 10
years old taking care of kids who were 3
years old and you know I mean it was
just startling for me so even a mother
was sometimes not a commonplace person
in their lives so the substitutional
effect of kids you know I blame parents
so yeah and then you know grandparents
yes the section reminds me of another
book Stephanie Coontz is the way they
never were and your film brings out that
those idealized visions that we have of
white America
middle class in the 1950s where the mom
stays home and makes the cookies yes
was only true for a very small portion
right right right people right and yet
the pervasiveness of the image of the
mom at home with the cookies right
cookies comes up a lot
Leave It to Beaver Leave It to Beaver
and owning a home the reforms that the
tax loss it's something else so I'm
actually gonna thank marlene booth for
coming today and for sharing the movie
with us and what I really would like to
do is to have more of our faculty take a
look at
it I think it has real applicability in
several different of our classes or
courses just a wonderful you know when
Marlene mentioned to me some of the work
that she's done over a wonderful kale
salad that she makes that I love you
know I got really excited and then when
I saw some of the emails that she sent
out about different books I mean
different play movies then and I showed
it to Jane wall Fogle Jane said oh my
god we have to invite her you know so
we're delighted to have you and would
you just join me in thanking her thank
you I'm just as delighted to be here
thank you very much